hello it's me calling please pick up
i need to show you how nice i look in
the new facetime portrait mode
please don't send this to voicemail
it's that time of the year again when i
show up in a phone screen to tell you
that there's a new apple iphone
operating system
there are a bunch of new features in ios
15.
you just need to know where to look
so here i am to help with 10 of my top
ios 15 tips
let's do this number one fix the safari
address bar
something very bad has happened apple
has moved the safari bar to the bottom
[Music]
perhaps this is because phones are so
big and it's annoying to reach to the
top of the screen
or because they wanted to make it easier
to do this and switch tabs either way
thank goodness you can set it back to
normal go to settings
safari
and tap single tab
look there are pluses to it being at the
bottom i get that but i'm old now and i
like having things where they belong at
the top number two convert photos to
text
see this little icon here it's the new
scan text button that shows up whenever
you have a text field
tap it and it will launch the camera for
a cool new trick okay so look at this
newspaper phone tap on the button
i come a little bit closer let's say we
want to do that section right there
and boom all of the text shows up you
will see all the scanned text load in
here but to insert it into your document
or text message press here you can now
also do this in your camera app if you
take a photo of something with text then
tap this button in the bottom right
it will make that photo's text editable
number three get info about your photos
here's a photo
don't even try to argue it this dog is
cuter than yours when you press this
information button apple tells you it's
a dog okay maybe not that impressive but
then i tapped here and it suggested it
was a cockapoo that's only slightly off
he's a cavapoo either way this feature
works for animals landmarks plants
flowers and more number four get weather
alerts
a few years ago apple bought dark sky
one of the best weather apps out there
and now apple's updating its built-in
weather app with a similar design and
some more weather detail
one of the best parts is notifications
about rain or snow starting in a
specific area to turn these on tap here
then here
then notifications
you can then customize your locations
number five face time with android and
windows pals
open facetime and you'll see a new
create link button tap it and you can
then share the link with your friends
and family on android or windows when
they click the link it will open the web
browser on their device and they'll be
asked to give access to their camera and
microphone
and then they'll be in the video call
oh half time break forgot to tell you
popcorn energy drink whatever you want
number six look and sound better in
video calls
press this button here in a facetime
call and you can enable portrait mode on
your video
no portrait mode
portrait mode
but you can also use portrait mode in
other video calling apps go to the
control center and hold video effects
and select portrait you can make
yourself sound better too by selecting
the mic mode button and selecting voice
isolation
number seven concentrate aka focus mode
sometimes there are certain parts of the
day where you don't want to hear from
certain people and certain apps like
right now i don't really want to hear
from anyone while i'm shooting a video
and now there's new modes that let you
do that
go to settings focus
and select personal
you can then add people and apps you
want notifications from when you're in
personal mode
then when you're ready to put your phone
in personal mode go to control center
and select it from here you can make all
sorts of different modes i made shooting
mode so i'm only interrupted by my
spouse and boss
number eight use siri offline so here's
what usually happens with siri you ask
it a question and it sends that query
and your audio to the cloud for
interpretation and then sends it back to
your device for a response but now siri
can do a handful of things without ever
needing to go to the cloud and without
ever needing an internet connection
okay so check this out i'm turning off
cellular and wi-fi airplane mode is on
hey siri
set a timer for 10 minutes
10 minutes counting down
hey siri set a timer for 5 minutes
there's already a ten minutes timer
replace it
no you should be able to set two timers
because it's 20 21. anyway the offline
feature works only for certain commands
hey siri launch wsj and the benefit
isn't just that you can do this when you
happen to be off-grid but it's also
faster
open messages you do have to have an
iphone 10s or later to get this feature
number nine hide your email
sometimes you don't want to share your
private email address with websites or
other people and now apple has a privacy
feature so you don't need to go to
settings
tap your name at the top
go to icloud
and then hide my email
you can create a new email address here
that you can send to others when people
email that address apple will then
forward that mail to your main email
address
the catch you only get this if you pay
for icloud plus which starts at 99 cents
a month for 50 gigabytes of storage with
this you also get a new privacy feature
called private relay which encrypts your
web browsing and hides your ip address
number 10 get a summary of notifications
instead of waking up every morning to a
long list of notifications you missed
apple will put together this summary for
you
go to settings notifications and turn on
schedule summary
then pick which app notifications are
important to you and when you want them
delivered
i know you clicked on this video and you
thought you were only getting 10 tips
but here's a bonus round hold down on a
photo in your photo library and you can
drag it to another app like messages or
mail
in safari you can now group tabs by
category or topic
and finally go to settings
accessibility
audio visual
and turn on background sounds
then you can go to control center
and tap here
and play some relaxing white noise
perhaps before stressing out about all
these new changes coming in ios 15.
right here's some birds in there